what would you say is you is between the
two of you is the biggest disagreement
about aliens
alien life out there
is it
from the basic framework of thinking
about what is life to maybe what aliens
look like to alien civilizations to ufo
sightings
what would you think
so i would say the biggest one is that
um
the emergence of life does not have to
be
um that can it can't just happen once on
the planet that it could be two or more
life forms present on the planet at once
and i think sarah doesn't agree with
that
i think that's like
logically inconsistent
that's really polite you're saying it's
nonsense
because you think that yeah how likely
is that so the idea that what is what
does it look like let's imagine
uh two alien civilizations coexisting on
a planet what's that look like exactly
so i would say um
i think i've got to get around your
argument okay yeah let's say that let's
say that on this planet there's just
like there's lots of available chemistry
and one life form gets some
emerges based on carbon and interacts
and there's a there's an ecosystem based
on carbon and there's an orthogonal
um
and so it's planetary phenomena which is
what you i think right but there's also
one that goes on silicon
and and because there's enough energy
and there's enough stuff
that these life forms might not actually
necessarily compete um
evolutionarily yeah but they would have
to not interact at all because they're
going to be co-constructing each other's
causal chains i think that's where you
just got me yeah so there's no so
there's no overlap
in terms of their causal change they're
very limited yeah so i think the only
way i can get away with that is to say
right life could emerge on a planet
underneath
and uh okay lizard people under the
crest of the europe i think i think i
think we let's go to i i i think
that but look as you can see we disagree
so and i think sarah actually has
convinced me because of that that life
is a planetary for not the emotional
life is a planetary phenomena and and
actually um because of the way evolution
selection works then nothing occurs in
isolation the causal chains interact so
there is a common there's a consensus
model for life on the earth but you
don't think you can place aliens
from elsewhere onto the can't you just
uh place multiple alien civilizations on
one planet right but i think
so you can take
two original life events that were
independent and co-mingle them but
i don't think when you're talking about
when you when you look at the
interaction of that structure it's it
it's like the same idea as like an
experiment being an example of life
right that's a really abstract and
subtle concept and i guess what i'm
saying is
life is information propagating through
matter so once you start having things
interacting
they in some sense commingle and they
become part of the same
chain
so there is a commingling starts quickly
yeah proceeds we proceed to co-mingle
quickly right right so you you could say
so the question is then
the more interesting question is are
there two distinct origins events and i
still think that there's reasons that on
a single planet you would have one
origins event because of the time scales
of cycling
of geochemistry on a planet and also the
fact that i don't think that the origin
of life happens in a pool and like
radiates outward through evolutionary
processes i think it's a multi-scale
phenomena it happens at the level of
individual molecules interacting
collections of molecules interacting and
entire planetary scale cycles so life as
we know it
has always been multi-scale and there's
i'm brilliant examples of individual
mutations at the genome level changing
global climate right so there's a tight
coupling between things that happen
at you know the largest scale our
planetary scale and the smallest scale
that life mediates but it still might be
difficult within something you will call
as a single civil alien civilization you
know different their species and stuff
but i think what yeah they can't might
not be able to communicate but you're
asking about life not species right so
what's the difference between
one
living civilization this this is almost
like a category question yeah
versus species because it can be very
different like the evolution because
there's like island like literally
islands you can involve different kinds
of turtles and stuff and they can
so i guess what i'm saying is weird if
you look at the structure of two
interacting
living things populations
and you look in their past and they have
independent origins for their causal
chain then you would say one was alien
you know they have different in
independent origins events but if you
look at their future by virtue of the
fact they're interacting their causal
chains have become co-mingled so that
and then in the future they they
they are not independent
um right right so that's why you would
even define them as aliens so the
structure across time is two examples of
life become one example of life because
life is the entire structure across time
right but there could be a lot of
variation with this yeah so the question
we're all interested in is how many
independent origins of a complexifying
causal chain are there in the universe
see but is the idea of origin
is easy for you to define
because like um well when the two when
the species split in the evolutionary
process
and you get like um
a dolphin versus a human or neanderthal
versus homo sapien that
isn't there let me make a distinction
here um quickly so i think um sorry to
interrupt um
what we're saying i mean i mean i mean
i mean sarah we won that argument
because she i think she's right that um
once the calls will change interact and
go forward so we're talking about a
number of things let's go all the way
back before origin of life origin life
on earth on earth
chemistry emerges there's so there's all
these i would say there's probably
mechanistically
the chemistry is desperately trying to
find anyway get replicators the ribosome
kind of
was really rubbish at the beginning and
they just competed completely competing
you got better and better ribosomes
suddenly that was a technology the
ribosome is the technology that way boom
allowed evolution to start
so what i was trying to why i
interrupted you is say that once
evolution has started using that
technology then
you can speciate and i was trying to and
i think what sarah said was convinced me
of because i was like no we can have
lots of different chemistry shadow
biosphere on earth and she's like no no
no
you have to have this you have to get to
this
minimum evolutionary
machine
and then when that occurs speciation
occurs exactly what it's like dolphins
humans
everything on earth
but when you're looking at aliens or
alien life um there's not gonna be two
different types of chemistry because
they compete they compete and interact
and cooperate because the causal chains
overlap one might kill the other one
might combine with the other and then
you go on and then you have this kind of
um this average and sure there might be
speciation it might be have two types of
emerging chemistry it almost looks like
the origin of life on earth required two
different pre-life forms the peptide
world and the rna world somehow they got
together and by combining
you got the ribosome and that was the
minimum competent entity for evolution
and
would all alien civilizations
have an evolutionary process
on a planet
so like that's one of the almost it's
almost the definition of life to create
all those memories you have to
have something like change in time yeah
and then but there has to be selection
um that's like an efficient there's no
other way to do it no i don't well never
say never because sooner say that's the
part that depresses me though going back
to like i don't know the earlier
discussion on violence and things like
and i i don't know where
somebody was tweeting about this
recently but like you know how much
stuff had to die maybe it was you yeah
ah yeah
so
yes sorry so we were talking we're
talking about life yeah and uh
i guess
a lot of murder had to occur right so
selection means drinks had to be weeded
out right so well we can celebrate that
death makes way for tulip yeah i mean it
and also you know one of the most
interesting features of major extinction
events in the history of our planet is
how much novelty emerged immediately
after
right so and of course you know a lot of
people make arguments we wouldn't be
here if the dinosaurs didn't go extinct
so
um
in some ways
we can attribute our existence to all of
that but i guess i was just wondering
and sort of like if i was going to build
a universe myself
in the most optimistic way would i
retain that feature but it does seem to
be a yeah you have to i mean i think
we're i think we're probably being over
um anthropomorphizing i remember
watching uh the blue i think it was the
blue planet david attenborough was
showing these seals and because of
climate change some seals were falling
off a cliff and how tragic it was i was
like
i'm saying my son
that's pretty cool look at look at those
ones down there they've obviously got
some kind of mutations some and they're
not doing that daft thing and so that
that that poor gene will be weeded out
of course at the individual level it
looks tragic and of course as human
beings have the ability to abstract and
we empathize we don't want to cause
suffering on other human beings and we
should retain that but we shouldn't look
back in time and say
you know how many butterflies
had to die
i remember making this
how many
if you think about the caterpillar
become the chrysalis and then the
butterfly getting out
how many if that suffering we call it
suffering if that process of pruning had
not occurred we have no butterflies so
none of the butterfly beauty in the
world without all that pruning so
pruning is required but we shouldn't
amphimorphize and feel sorry for the
biological entities
but because that's that seems to be a
backwards way of looking at it what we
should do is project forward and maybe
think about what values we have across
our species our ecosystem and our fellow
human beings you know you know now that
we know that animals suffer at some
level
think about humane farming when we find
that plants can in fact are conscious
and can think and have pain then we'll
do
um humane gardening
until that point we won't do it right
i like this
um
famous chemist endorses the majestic
nature of murder that's such a that's
the title
um i didn't say that but okay well i
just it's inserted i have a hard time
with it though i think the way you put
it it's kind of
but it it's the reality of it's the
reality of it is beautiful
um you know there's an instagram account
called nature's metal
and i i keep following and unfollowing
it because i can't handle it for
prolonged periods of time we evolve
together you die alone
yeah we evolved together well you die
alone so i you live alone too it's the
gatsby thing i don't know
we evolved together where's the together
the together is the murder the
population and the secrets i just love
my romantic vision of it to try to make
me happy sarah instead of sad sarah
i talk in third person when i think very
abstractly sorry um
is um
you know like like this whole like you
know the like certain things can
co-exist so the universe is trying to
maximize existence but there's some
things that just
aren't
the most projective productive
trajectory together but it doesn't mean
that they don't exist on another
timeline or another chain somewhere else
like i like and maybe you would call
that like then some kind of multiverse
or things but
what am i saying
i think you can't i just you can't go
down just making stuff up no you're not
no matter
i don't underst it is illogical and we
need we know i know if you look at
bacteria if you look at virus i mean
just
just the number of organisms that are
constantly like looking at bacteria
they're just dying non-stop right
slaughter right so well and this goes
back to conversation about god i mean
like there's the whole thing about like
why is the universe enable suffering
individuals don't exist right in
individual so for this i think if you
think about life as an entity on earth
right
let's just let's just go back a second i
mean i like to i'll be ludicrous for a
second i don't exist you don't exist
right
um but you but the actions you do the
product of evolution exists right the
objects you create exist
quantitatively in the real world if you
then understand life on earth or alien
life or any life in the universe there's
this integrated entity
where you need you need cells in your
body to die otherwise you'd just get
really big
and you wouldn't be able to walk around
right so you know
you do yeah yeah
yeah so yeah so i think
the patterns that persist not the
physical thing and of course we you know
we have we have we place immense values
on fellow human beings and i'm
my majestic professor does like other
individual human beings or now you're
talking in third person too i know it
happens right so death would you say i
mean because you said evolution is a
fundamental part of uh
life so death is a fundamental part of
life yeah
it might right now it might not be in
the future we might hack some aspects of
death
we could and will evolve in different
ways but isn't there i i think sarah
mentioned like this life density
um is it can't that become a problem
like too much
to too much uh bureaucracy too much of
baggage uh builds up like you need to
keep
erasing okay that we dissipate like i
don't think of like like dissipation yes
no but i mean like like we're so fixated
on ourselves as individuals and and
agents and we were talking about this
last night actually um over dinner but
like um you know an individual persists
for a certain amount of time
but what you want to do like if you're
really concerned with immortality is not
to live
indefinitely as an individual but
maximize your causal impact so like what
are the traces of you that are left
and and you're still a real i always
think of einstein like for a period of
time he was a real physical thing we
would identify as a human and now we
just see echoes of that human in all the
ways that we talk about his you know
causal impact or frankly right is
another great example because how many
easter eggs could you leave in the
future so i got yeah
so i guess the the question is how much
do you want to control the localization
of uh certain features
of say a prop a packet of propagating
information we might call a person and
keep them localized to one individual
physical structure do you wanna you know
is there a time when that just becomes a
dissipated feature
of
the society that it once existed in and
i'm okay with the dissipative feature
because i just think
that makes more room for more creativity
in the future
you